euromax highlights and here's your host
louise howton hello and welcome to the
show which covers a wide variety of
topics from all around europe we start
off in paris on the subject of fashion
but before we come to that here's a
taste of what else is coming up in the
next half an hour
design icon german fashion king wolfgang
yup is still going strong
fleeting images featuring a dutch
photographer and his indoor clouds
and bella italia we spend a day on the
canals of venice
an author furniture designer illustrator
and one of the judges on the tv reality
show germany's next top model that is
what wolfgang yoke is now known for
aside from his clothing line of course
design has always been his passion and
he was recently in paris at fashion week
presenting his latest collection which
has been influenced by his international
lifestyle
models in ankle boots and eye-catching
camouflage trousers
it's a mix of summer and winter couture
with a vibrant combination of fabrics
and color
it's a tribute to dadaism made in
wunderkind studios in potsdam even
though designer borthgang yeop was a
world away working in l.a
i made the calls at night and we did
fittings on the phone and with skype
they sent the clothes over in a suitcase
but of course there were all these
influences because life in los angeles
can be just as multi-faceted as it is in
germany i think
during the fitting yop works with
stylists and his team to develop the
finished look
boring
perhaps closing the blizzard like really
up we make you also a button something a
button or whatever like something like
that completely closed
you know
do you think that's better perhaps yeah
i mean i don't know
then she can put her perhaps her hands
in here
you see it it gives a good look
it's like like um like a sports jacket
you always have have your hands like
that
finally the designer is satisfied
okay
guys
i channel the spirits and they speak to
me i also think i have a great ability
to quote and recall images that i've
seen before and place them in a new
context
that's called post-modernism
anything that's modern
is just
it's all made up i just put it in a new
context where it clashes
for his new collection job even enlisted
the help of his two grandchildren to
design some prints
we worked together and signed it on the
back
that's what they call me helena and
fritz it's down here on the seam
there's also a rabbit with a carrot and
a fox that wants to eat the rabbit
they're focused in housing
the fashion designer will soon be
celebrating his 70th birthday but he
hasn't lost his creative passion he says
it's the best way to stay young
it reminds me that i have a purpose
i have an experiment that i need to
watch whether it blows up in my face or
takes off
curiosity makes me do it again and again
here wolfgang yup is on his way to his
next show
backstage the models are getting ready
to hit the catwalk
as the guests find their seats
cristiano arp editor-in-chief of vogue
germany and wolfgang's daughters
florentina
we keep asking ourselves how long is he
going to keep this up
but we have to keep supporting him
it's important that he knows he has a
family backup system we don't do
everything together but it's important
for him to have support
well-meaning support
and then the models hit the stage
40 different looks are featured in yop's
latest collection
his grandchildren's animal drawings even
make an appearance in the show
and the unconventional creations of the
potsdam-based designer seem to have hit
the mark with the international audience
his designs aren't as commercial as
those of other designers
you can feel wolfgang's freedom and his
artistic sensitivity
it's like i'm giving it away we worked
on it for so long and then i feel so
useless on the day and i have to say it
makes me feel powerless it's like having
something taken away from me and then
i'm standing in front of an empty plate
and have to start cooking again
but wolfgang yo won't be heading to the
kitchen tonight his next stop is a paris
restaurant with his daughters
the idea of creating a cloud inside is
quite a novel one but it's the
brainchild of dutch artist bear
schmilder
he captures the indoor clouds with his
camera and his work has been picked up
by advertisers and fashion labels we
accompanied him on a shoot to see how he
creates his surreal shots
these are not computer-enhanced pictures
but real clouds in real rooms
dutch artist bernout smilda calls this
series of pictures nimbus
he's fascinated by ambiguity
clouds can be many things and they can
be threatening but on the other hand
there can also be like a divine
situation almost so there's always this
duality in the work as well
same as it builds up but at the same
time it falls apart again so it's just
there for a few seconds
so it's really about something that
happened on that location is then
afterwards it's gone
smilda who lives in amsterdam has been
creating indoor clouds since 2010
he's been invited to work at the saint
peter's church in cologne the church
nave is regularly used for art projects
the pictures created here will be on
view in his next exhibition
the space is almost like the plinth for
the work and i like it when there's a
double connection as an as an exhibition
space but also as a former user in this
case as a church
smelta's cloud pictures cost up to 8 000
euros
and they are less science and technology
heavy than you might think
i work with a fog machine
and with water and it's just water paper
that i use and the idea is that
there's a burst of
smoke going into the space and i build a
wall with water vapor on the position
where about i want to position the
clouds so that should be in the middle
somewhere here so i make the space wet
and cold
and
build a wall of vapor where the smoke
bumps into and the water kind of sticks
to the smoke makes it heavier and pours
it down so it keeps it together for just
a few seconds maybe depending on the
space because every space works
differently
lamps in the room imitate the sun
the way the smoke refracts the light
determines the mood of the cloud
and in order to get the perfect shot
smilda spends days running tests
and during that phase he doesn't like
people to watch
by doing a performance you would you
would make a different
work i think then it will be about a
collective memory and people will be
standing here and then the work would
also be about how do you make something
and and for me it's more about the idea
that counts and the idea of this cloud
inside the space so therefore i just
want to have this image
smelda's pictures are fascinating
last year he staged renowned designers
alongside his clouds for the
international fashion magazine harper's
bazaar
he often enlists the help of a
professional photographer
after all he's striving for technically
perfect pictures
the u.s magazine time chose his clouds
as one of the most important inventions
of 2012.
it has spread around quite fast via the
internet and i think it's yeah it's like
a really
universal timeless image maybe that's
why so many people are
like it in a way
merton outsmelda's cloud pictures foster
awareness of transients
by capturing it for posterity
the invention of the internet has had
huge impacts on the majority of
industries one that has seen significant
changes over the last 20 years is the
music business songs are more accessible
now and there are so many unsigned
artists publishing their work online in
the hopes of building a fan base and
being discovered
well now there is a new way for them to
be proactive and collaborate with some
of the biggest names in the industry via
a new app called whole world band
station you need the money
use whatever you want you can use some
um
japanese
drums or bells or the kitchen sink or
just uh
an old t-chest whatever you want to do
bang on it saxophone blah blah anything
you want
you need the money ever fancy jamming
with a rolling stone whole world band
makes it possible
anyone can add their own video and audio
track to this work in progress
simi crowns from dublin is a regular
user of whole world band the tools of
the trade here are just an ipad and a
microphone the creep in the monsters do
they trust who they love there's
different options of searching for
different types of songs you can search
by genre
you can search by um
the name of bands you can search by seed
track um
c track is basically whoever contributes
the the background of the whole session
now the nigerian irish rapper tracks
down the seed and adds new life with his
own input
whole world band is the brainchild of
kevin godley former 10cc member and half
of godly and cream it was launched
together with an irish startup
i suppose i'm trying to create an audio
visual global recording studio
whereby
somebody in this country can play with
somebody in another country relatively
easily
i call the technology behind it somewhat
pretentiously digilog
because it's using digital technology to
create a fundamentally analog experience
a virtual studio that you can record in
by tapping your own tablet the network
already has several thousand musicians
signed up including the likes of ronnie
wood
former police drummer stuart copeland
and english singer-songwriter passenger
and there's plenty of incentive for the
big names too
there's a slight sort of game edge to it
a competitive edge to it
can anybody out there do something i'm
not expecting and if so can i use it
how about some traditional drumming this
japanese group is taking a time out from
their european tour to record a seed
track with kevin godley
they love the idea of collaborating with
artists from other genres
the name whole world band says it all
this program allows us to communicate
musically with people all over the world
you perform together and create new
music in the process
it's exciting
users can buy a recording session
costing a maximum of 6 euros and 23
cents if a composite song ends up being
released all the artists who contribute
get a share of the proceeds
it's i think the first time we've
monetized sharing uh
we're breaking down barriers to
something that was traditionally very
closed and exclusive um you know where
musicians went
hid in a studio for for months
recording sumi crowns has yet to earn
any money from his contributions but for
the 24 year old it's more a labor of
love learning and sharing
and the fun factor is just as high too
i don't really see any issues in terms
of the two going side by side the actual
live sessions you know meeting with
people and actually making music in the
same environment and the virtual
environment so i think it's um
complementary to each other
so would one replace the other no would
the two go together very well absolutely
sharing the virtual stage with mega
stars or with the rising talents of
tomorrow this app gives you an access
all areas
whole world band bringing the planet
another bit closer in the new digital
era of sight and sound
now here's a little fact for you
every sound that you hear when you're in
a car is actually engineered to sound
the way it does this design process
covers everything from the noise the
windows make to the click of the
indicators and the sound of the throttle
one noise that many car lovers think the
louder the better
from 0 to 100 in 4.5 seconds and with
top speeds of 300 kilometers an hour the
911 is a dream machine for sports car
lovers
but porsche employees bernhard feflin
and bantamilla have more than pure pace
on their minds
the sound underscores the experience the
emotions the enjoyment which is why it's
an essential factor for me
the two acoustic designers work on
honing the sound of each model at the
company's r d center near the city of
stuttgart
on their recommendations engineers
adjust air supply and exhaust alignment
in order to influence the noise of the
engine
the more we accelerate the more intense
the sound those two things have to go
together to create a harmonious ensemble
the engineers don't only rely on their
own ears to determine what sounds good
they use a dummy that simulates human
hearing as well as various microphones
to record and analyze engine sounds
the construction of the engine can then
be changed according to their findings
the acoustic designers get down to work
as soon as the first concept for each
new model is born
in the concept
during the concept phase there is
neither an engine nor a car which means
everything has to be simulated
we simulate the intake
the engine and the exhaust
to create a sound we have to experiment
a lot and can try as many as 240
variations
other car manufacturers including opel
also have acoustic departments they
employ up to 200 people to make sure
every model has its own unmistakable
timbre
they also run tests with potential
customers
at the institute for acoustics at
berlin's technical university he has
been researching the sound of cars for
more than 30 years
his company has worked for manufacturers
from around the world
and you take anxiety italian cars sound
different compared to german or english
ones and asian cars are different from
european models
they have a low frequency they're
relatively quiet and very pleasant
in europe and in italy in particular
you're looking at high frequency sounds
higher engine speeds
then in england they have a deeper sound
a morgan for example
bubbles
but the designers are not only
interested in the sound the engine makes
they also have to factor in more than a
hundred functional noises such as the
closing of a door these days every sound
is specially designed
it closes smoothly not like
electric cars present the soundsmiths
with new challenges
they are particularly quiet when they
drive slowly so quiet in fact that
experts in the eu are currently
discussing whether they should create
automatic warning signals and not just
for safety reasons
we optimized the combustion engine over
125 years and we know how to build one
to make a particular sound
so now the challenge posed by electric
engine signifies revolution rather than
evolution
we don't know exactly what the customers
want to hear
do they want to hear anything or are
they happy to have a quiet car
for many porsche 911 fans silence would
be anything but golden but then again
this car is no everyday vehicle
we finished the show today in the
italian city of venice a place that's
known for being a romantic destination
for a weekend trip of course some people
live and work in these surroundings all
year round so we went to explore what
it's like to be a gondolier and navigate
visitors around the canals
the world famous saint mark square in
venice
the best way to see the city's landmarks
is on the water
when i was little my father took me
along and taught me how to row
this is part of life in venice
it's lovely it it it
gives a different perspective on venice
when you when you see it from a gondola
luciano pelecholi's gondola is muscle
powered using an ore on one side called
the ramo
now aged 48 he's been doing this for
decades but it's still hard work to
steer the 10 meter long boat through the
narrow canals
careful we don't want to fall into the
water
phoenician gondolas are works of art in
themselves
luciano pelicholi paid 50 000 euros for
his
he had a built to his own specifications
out of nine types of wood lutano
pelicoli rose the british tourist
through san polo the oldest part of
venice
about 5000 people still live here in the
old town but surprisingly few tourists
find their way through the narrow
streets alleys and canals
i like this neighborhood because i was
born and raised here
i feel very close to this part of town
i learned to swim in this corner over
there
when i was baby
long long time ago
the gondoliers profession looks back on
a long tradition starting in the 11th
century the city's well-to-do would have
themselves rolled around the city in
gondolas fitted with small cabins called
felsi
back when residents depended on gondolas
for transportation there were over ten
thousand on venice's canals
today only some 500 are left used mainly
by tourists
luciano pelicioli moores his gondola
beneath the famous rialto bridge one of
the most confident spots in venice
there's no shortage of tourists passing
by drumming up his business is part of
the gondola's job
good afternoon senora just 80 euros
80 euros will pay for a 45-minute
gondola ride the prices are standardized
according to strict guidelines
the licensed gondolieri have attended a
special school learned the city's
history and studied foreign languages
many people dream of becoming a
gondolier there are only 400 gondoliers
with a license
this profession immerses you completely
in this city
luciano pelecholi spends up to 14 hours
a day rolling his passengers through the
canals but he doesn't sing for them
amateur singers are no longer welcome on
the gondolas only professionals
well that brings us nicely to the end of
the show for today so thank you for
being with us and until next time take
care of yourselves and goodbye
you